you don't even know
you know this is this is like this got
netflix all over it
i'm telling you
you know hbo max and netflix they're
going to be battling it out over she
ain't got time for that
big bear mountain
a weightlifting competition
a stock broker
six sisters
a plane crash
three pennies
gambling addiction
friday at midnight
benefits of hard work
a man on the run
[Music]
and lastly this piece of dialogue
she ain't got time for that
again you don't have to use all 11.
okay
you know i've actually seen some
some movies about these things
all right
let's see
[Music]
well you know um
a lot of these are really classic
um
and
i mean i'm almost inclined to like
string many of them together into like
like the string some of them actually
into like one
um
but i don't think i'll do that um
so like if i were to like take something
like uh
like
gambling addiction um
i
don't really think that that is a
a cause or an effect
so to speak so you'd have to kind of
develop a cause and effect
around it
so so um you'd have like something like
um
a
a
[Music]
police officer
with
a gambling addiction
um
must
um
must
resolve
his debt
to
a
notorious
gangster
okay
by
murdering his partner
the officers partner or the gangster's
partner
no he is uh um
the um the cops partner oh wow okay
so what that
what that that that creates is
um a cause and effect um
it's it's it's it's not the cause is
resolving is dead
you know it's not it's it it's not the
gambling addiction the gambling
addiction is his uh i forget what it's
there's actually a name for it i want to
say misbehavior but i don't think that's
the correct one
but
it it does not it it may predicate
the cause but it's not a part of the
cause
the effect is that he has to
he has to um
to kill his partner which is
kind of
effed up
so so so yeah that's how that one would
work um
a man on the run
there's so many men on the run movies
you know it's like it's like things that
always happens
you know it's like the big cliche
oh a man on the run
after
run
after
a bank heist
um
after a bank heist
and this is not the officer
no no this is different okay um
thank guys
i'm stuck here
after thank heist
i want to say
but i don't think it's going to work
um must
reconcile
this is dopey
um
with his daughter
who ultimately
turns him in
okay
um it's getting interesting yeah let's
see um let's take another one
three lucky pennies
no or three pennies
retrieved from the bottom of the
fountain
bottom of a fountain
bestow
three wishes
that
reverse
into curses
um
let's see
a weightlifting
competition
turned
turns into
two
weightlifting competition
there's something there's another
element that needs to be in there
because there's no real cause
established
a weightlifting competition
a weightlifting competition
ah that's because
it needs
a bodybuilder
entering
a weight lifting competition
competition
meets
his
lifelong idol
and
and has
conflicted
the long premise
uh feelings
competing
against him
after learning
after learning so the drama of course
he's fighting cancer
what you want to do is you want to learn
to make that shorter
for your kids out there
all right um
friday at midnight
a young
uh
what's he do
um
a young high school dropout
in
the 1950s
discovers
his
his um
his purpose
fridays
at midnight
drag racing
at
the
vocal
street
oh no dragging dry racing on the
off streets
of this small town
there you go
now let's see um
what else we got here let's tackle she
ain't got time for that because that
one's just weird
[Laughter]
that one's just odd
hey
a tv
comedian
is
by
the role
she played
on screen
and
is
becomes
violently
ill
every time
a fan
utters
her
famous catchphrase
[Laughter]
catchphrase
actually i'm gonna write this one
she ain't got time for it
you don't even know
you know this is this is like this got
netflix all over it
i'm telling you
you know hbo max and netflix they're
going to be battling it out over she
ain't got time for that
no
um all right um
let's see what else is here
a stock broker
trading
and high finance
on wall street
starts
selling shares
man
let's just go for really fantastical
starts
showing shares
in the afterlife
done
um
[Music]
six sisters
six sisters
spur-lunking
[Laughter]
i'm sorry what does that mean
oh it's like it's cave diving oh okay
[Laughter]
okay um
[Music]
get
trapped
in
and
losing oxygen
must soon
come
to
the decision
of
who lives or dies
before someone rescues them
someone
rescues
rescues them
how many do you have left over eleven
one two
three wow i did all them
great okay can you combine the remaining
three into one log line
um yeah i'll try yeah okay um
actually you know
this is pretty set up for me right there
to be honest um
this one it does have a cause
[Music]
in
in big bear mountain
the survivors
of
a plane crash
it's pretty it's writing itself
[Laughter]
must
save
the injured
through i'll just make it simple through
the benefits
of hard work
and
cooperation
so which of which log line is your
favorite that you've created oh that's
one easy
one
it's a tv comedian is haunted by
a tv comedian is haunted by the role she
played on screen and becomes violently
ill every time a fan utters her famous
catchphrase she ain't got time for that
that's a winner
and why do you why does that resonate so
much for you
well it's not so much that it resonates
um it's it's that that's not at all why
it resonates um the nature of a log line
is is is a couple of things and these
many of these if not all of these and i
was having fun
um um
violate
um
pretty much the strict rules of a log
line and and one of those is that
is brevity
a long line should be concise that one's
not so concise but it does the other
thing a long line should do
it
grabs your attention
so then
so
technically a log line is is something
that if you're over conversation
over dinner um
you
can say casually to your dinner guest
uh or to whoever it is or even if you're
just you're pitching it over dinner
and you can just
let it roll off your tongue
and it have a sort of ring to it
you know and a ring and a verisimilitude
you know then
then
usually
or hopefully
someone responds to it like oh well
that's nice oh that's interesting
i'd like to see that you know it's it's
it's the thing that sort of makes you go
i want to know more
and that's really the
the objective that's the purpose
of a log line um because it
i mean well
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna back that up
too
the log line also helps you design your
screenplay that is one that's that's
another purpose you can use it for but
at the end of the day when you're done
with your screenplay and you've
you've refined your log line
and you make it concise
you need to be able to give it to the
world and use it as a hook
so a lot of the log lines that you came
up with you said they were too long
especially the one that you really loved
that it's got to be shorter so if we
were going to take let's say the log
line for fargo i know you
said you liked the coen brothers work
yeah
or a serious man or something like what
what how would we shorten that down
because because that would be hard a
serious man that would be kind of
difficult to have a shorter long line
with that i don't know there i mean if
you look up
if you you
you know there's there there are smarter
men than me
that have um
defined the log lines for for those
films and you can look them up you can
google them um and they they're very
brief actually i've read one for a
serious man and it's uh
it's it's it's it it is kind of brief if
you want to borrow the allegory from
something else to describe like movies
like that it's
usually you know it's not you don't have
to reach too far
um
like um
you know um
a you know a what is a serious man's
like a cancer diagnosis leads to a
journey of discovery for um
a man that often considered himself
invisible and now
um
comes to
comes to a sense of um rebirth
you know i mean that that's
the the it it's pretty simple you know
and and what it is is like and if any
writer or writer who's a reader i would
say
is like when they see a movie like a
serious man or they
are familiar with the script a serious
man they'll go well this is just
um
the odyssey by homer
you know it's pretty it's the same thing
you know and believe me the calm
brothers knew it was the odyssey by
homer as they were writing it
um it's um
it's kind of a blatant
[Laughter]
who was psy in the odyssey
i don't know but i think maybe the the i
would say he was the cyclops
the the the he they they
they've returned to the odyssey um again
and again the audi they actually did an
explicit interpretation of the odyssey
with oh brother whereof
um or brother where though is the
odyssey beat by beat
um
remember um john goodman
um at the tree with the patch on his eye
he is the cyclops
um
so um
so yeah yeah
and so with this what would be the title
for this comedian who who's really just
repulsed by this famous role that she's
known for and all the fans want to
repeat it to her what would you call it
oh i that well it's in the it's in the
log line it's the it's the catch phrase
she ain't got time for that okay
and why why does that make her ill why
why does she not like that role
well
it makes her violently ill
like physically
in in in the way i would foresee it so
like
um
she would have actual
uh physical reaction she would convulse
she would she would she and and it would
become progressively worse and and
manifest itself in probably some very um
gruesome strange way
um and and take it to its to it's
inexorable extreme
so
i i have fun with it it's a it's a very
humorous
um
um
premise and um i i
i enjoyed it i i rarely actually write
things like that but i also but i do
find those kind of things entertaining
and you know what i end up doing is
usually this is like um i um i take
things like that
and i i
make them quite serious along the way
you know that's why i like the cone
brothers because you know they
they're they're
they're they're satirists in a serious
way quite often